let's bring in dave rubin host of the
reuben report and author of don't burn
this country surviving and thriving in
our awoke dystopia i mean you saw the
video dave it sure looks like an
attempted double homicide and the
punishment clearly did not fit the crime
no it absolutely doesn't fit but this is
exactly what's been going on in la for a
couple years now and let's not forget
that george gascon you know his previous
job before being district attorney of
los angeles he was district attorney i
think for seven years in san francisco
and everyone watching fox news knows
everything they need to know about san
francisco it is an absolute dystopian
nightmare filled with crime and drugs
and homelessness and everywhere else
everything else and then what happens in
the world of progressive politics
especially in california you export that
from san francisco and now it's down in
los angeles and unfortunately you know
until the people of los angeles and
california more broadly decide to start
voting for some other people until that
california decides that it can no longer
be a one-party state then this is going
to keep happening there is going to be
more crime there are going to be lighter
sentences and more chaos on the streets
trey i used to see you all the time at
the fox la affiliate and guess what i
now live in the free state of florida
and this is a perfect example of why
yeah it is uh you know we were talking
about this with bill just a few moments
ago but george gaston says the teen will
be held accountable i just want to give
you a little peek inside this juvenile
probation camp the behavior management
program uses a point system to reward
your child for good behavior and the
points earned can be traded to obtain
items at the bmp store used to buy snack
items like cookies potato chips personal
items lotion shampoo writing paper and
or activities such as movie nights and
time in the game room what message are
we sending our young people here dave
i mean that sounds pretty sweet i know
it's it's tough to get a ps5 right now
maybe they could give you some bonus
points so you could get some more
weapons on fortnite or something i mean
this is just it's just so consistent
with everything that they do
in los angeles and california
progressives they punish good law
abiding citizens and they reward
criminals this kid should be in jail and
actually you know you could really go a
step further let's let the kids slide
george gascon should probably be in jail
or at least impeach for complete
dereliction of his duties yeah but we
keep seeing these far left da's like
gascon like chase of bodine and they and
they are deflecting right you know bill
talked about this where all of a sudden
the d.a the gas going saying oh i
checked this with with the sheriff here
at la county he said the sentence was
fine the sheriff's like bs i never said
any such thing i mean that's that's a
problem dave
oh it absolutely is a problem and by the
way i have great sympathy for the
sheriff villanueva who does has been
doing a great job he is fighting
completely uphill i mean he's fighting
his d.a right he's fighting his mayor
he's fighting the entire city basically
he's been fighting the city for a long
time when it came to mass mandates and
vaccine mandates and what they were
doing forcing police officers to be
injected and everything he's doing
everything he can and he's getting a
defunded police department obviously
he's really fighting hard i'm glad to
see that he's you know telling the truth
and then of course bill's not getting
the answer uh back from gascon's office
uh but you know we need good people to
stand up and that's the only way this
thing turns around but again more and
more people i mean the real issue here
is that more and more people will see
videos like that they will say boy the
administration the mayor doesn't have
our back the d.a doesn't have our back
there are greener pastures out there and
that's why california lost something
like 300 000 people last year and
they're moving to places like tennessee
texas and florida including you and i
just want to put this up there because
this is the mother we saw she and her
son almost run down killed she says
quoting here i was also told that his
record would be wiped clean when he
turns 18. how on earth can that be he
tried to murder two innocent pedestrians
murder and we have video evidence my
child would be dead if i hadn't been
there to protect him
ten seconds to wrap us up dave
i have incredible sympathy with her the
mother and i have no sympathy for george
gescon and and recall gascon like
they're doing up to chesa bodine up in
san francisco yeah dave rubin good to
see you thank you for coming on we
appreciate it if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell